Oh folks how's everybody hope you're
doing fine when I announced today first
again that we have a conference coming
up in Lusaka that will be April the
fourth you can find more information
there at that link there okay so if you
want to participate well better make
plans starting today okay yeah we
usually have a lot of fun at those
conferences I want to get the quickly
into some of the comments I'm gonna deal
with too many comments today but I do
want to address a couple of them and
here's one of them so I can get it up
here
there goes and it says do you believe
that there are such things as spiritual
beings like man is a spiritual being
with a body but angels are pure spirit
okay I think it is okay for us to
conceive of them as concepts because
concepts exist but not as physical okay
this would this is his notion this
gentleman and when we reply well I'll
put it next to his so we can see it side
by side you know if an angel wants to
exist you've got to fulfill the
definition of the word exist we have to
define the word exist and as you can see
it's defined its physical presence it
requires an object only objects can be
said to exist and concepts cannot be
said to exist not in science and as you
can see by that definition there is no
provision for belief okay something does
not exist because you believe that it
exists okay
now you might say they it exists for me
you know because you believe in it right
so so you have this notion that
something exists a cat exists or a dog
exam or a table exists because you
believe that it exists okay that's your
opinion because the dog exists for you
it doesn't exist for this other person
who says no that dog that you're talking
about doesn't exist and
we get into opinions and beliefs and
that's why it's not scientific it's
religion in science it's very simple we
defined the word exist if it meets the
specification it exists by definition
the definition is one more time put it
up there just so everybody gets it
physical presence it has to be an object
cannot be in a concept if an angel wants
to exist
the angel has to be an object to begin
with it's got to have shape like that
one there and then we can talk about
whether it has location or not okay but
that's the the first condition is that
it has to have it has to be an object
okay okay I hope that settles a lot of
stuff you don't have to believe in my
view you don't have to accept math you
don't have to agree to the theory okay
add to the definition if you don't like
the definition you only have you have a
single recourse that's to provide an
alternative definition that we can use
consistently rationally scientifically
second comment fella says something
trouble getting disease up there today
second individual says regarding the
block universe right determinism and
seemingly probabilistic behavior are not
mutually exclusive if you consider an
external agent and this individual go
through an explanation of how someone
designs something out there you don't
know about it etc etc you know I'm not
going to go through his entire argument
although I'm going to say in fact you
can read it maybe one of the comments
there what do we say to that well we say
that it doesn't matter whether you know
or not and it doesn't matter the issue
is not whether someone forced you to do
something supreme being out there the
klingons the the guys who created this
hologram here we don't care we're not
talking about you being forced to do
something
gunpoint 'men we're saying that someone
knows what you're gonna do already
without it without a shadow of a doubt
without error okay
and that's different than knowing for
sure you know some people say well you
know if I leave my cookies out there for
my little girl
I know she's gonna grab those cookies
that's not knowing because for all we
know you know your girl trips doesn't
make it to the cookies makes it to the
hospital instead and the cookies are
still there so you did not know okay
yeah people confuse intelligent guesses
with knowing knowing means that you run
an experiment and know without you know
and you can predict the results without
a shadow of a doubt and if there was an
error
then you did not predict you did not
know you just had an intelligent guess
people confuse those two things no here
here let me put in to context here's the
first context and here we have mr. Felix
and he's gonna throw this horseshoe and
it's gonna go right through the window
he's gonna commit a crime he's gonna
break a window in that market okay now
does Felix have a choice does he have
free will or in my is he following the
Specht that I wrote for him if I drew
this if I made this film does Felix have
any choice does he have free will that's
the first issue the second issue is this
one here we have God he's got a filing
cabinets okay up there in heaven and
he's got your file it doesn't mean that
God forced you to do something it means
God knows exactly what you're gonna do
because it's already printed on his file
cabinet he knows what you're gonna do
exactly he knows what you're thinking he
knows when you're sinning already before
you send and so if God is omniscient
there is no way you can avoid not have
you feel and that's the issue that's
been
bugging theists for 1,000 2,000 years
now
they cannot reconcile God submissions
with free will and they've been debating
this issue for that long and it hasn't
been settled you can look it up I mean
you'll find out that they're still
debating the issue and they'll invoke
Authority and they'll say look this is
what Augustine said this is what Aquinas
said and so on they'll go through the
whole rigmarole why because they haven't
settled it's just that simple and you
can't solve it and because the issues
not that God's gonna force you to do
something the issue is that God knows
that you're going to do it no matter
what so in that sense you are more or
less like Felix there okay okay that's
it for comments let me get into the
subject matter and the subject matter
today is mr. st. Thomas Aquinas and I'm
saying that he invented quantum
mechanics title of this presentation and
you say what does Aquinas have to do
with quantum mechanics well very simple
he introduced angels and you say well
what does angels what do angels have to
do with what quantum mechanics well
in order to explain certain magical
features of angels
what Aquinas did was invoke points and
lines of geometry he went to the Greeks
used those arguments to show that you
know you can prove through argument
etcetera that angels have all these
magical properties they can go through
things they can be many of them can be
at the same place at the same time one
angel can be at several places at the
same time etc which sounds a lot like
quantum mechanic particles so it's up to
the you know non-believer the naysayer
who tooth or devil's advocate to tell me
in what way particles in angels
particles of quantum mechanics and
angels of mr. Aquinas
thousand years ago how they're any
different they had the same properties
and the issue is that he based it on
what the Greeks had developed now the
guy who's known mostly for developing
geometry from the Greeks is Euclid okay
and he wrote a book 3rd century BC the
title elements the elements of geometry
and you know people give him a lot of
credit
I give you very little credit because I
think he was he was a guy who simply
compiled it all you know put it all
together what he learned in school in
those days the general knowledge that
was around and he just put it in a book
now whether he put any new material in
there something of his it's it's hard to
know but for sure a lot of that stuff
already was nobody just about every
Greek that dealt with philosophy
geometry etc in mathematics so Euclid
was not the first guy to come up with
all this stuff by a longshot and here I
made a little chart that puts it in the
right perspective ok here you have the
Greeks from different ages you have from
the 6th century all the way to Euclid
which is around the 3rd century and you
heard of some of these names here and
there and you'll see that the rich
already had quite a mastery of geometry
by the time you click was born and you
have the Union School the Pythagorean
school the old the Attic school and
you'll see the little colors there and
shows you more or less where these
people set their schools they're the
center of their schools
ok and you know the Greeks that traveled
around the Mediterranean so they knew
they moved around we're not a static
Society especially the rich people they
moved around and yeah by the time we get
to Euclid you know
he just learned what all these people
had already developed in fact I would
not even give credit to these early
Greeks because they they probably
inherited a lot of stuff from the
Egyptians and the Persians who probably
inherited some of that stuff or learned
that stuff from the Indians or the East
you know it's very hard to know we lose
track of who really developed what the
point is that by the time it gets to the
to Euclid he formalizes all this
knowledge and you know he's really not
the first but one of the books or one of
the series of books at one of the
schools he didn't realize upon is
Aristotle's Aristotle he founded a what
is known as the Lyceum in Athens and
it's a little quick story on that just
in case so that we put in the right
perspective Aristotle was the tutor of
Alexander the Great when he was a kid
and Philip the second in Aristotle's
father brought him over and said you
know I want you to be my kids teacher
and so you know Alexander learned a lot
from Aristotle and they became friends
so when thud died he was murdered you
know who they taught and in Alexander
took over by that time Athens and the
Thebans they rebelled they rebelled
against the Macedonians you keep it
monkey pin mind that Aristotle was a
Macedonian okay
and what happened was that they rebelled
against the Macedonians try to get him
off their shoulder you know and Aaron at
that moment in time you know era
Alexander was in charge of the troops he
went down there he beat the hell out of
the Thebans and the Athenians they kind
of backed off and became you know
continued paying tribute to to Macedonia
and uh
time that's when Aristotle comes to
Athens around that time and he become he
comes to the Lyceum Lyceum was a place
where all the Greeks call Athenians
would gather to discuss politics at do
gymnastics and philosophize you know
about these issues physics and so on
geometry and when Aristotle comes in
there he just turns it officially into a
school and he gave lectures there okay
some of the students took notes and they
wrote books and so a lot of these books
are what we have today a lot of people
will think that Aristotle was a great
genius you know that'd better all this
stuff personally I don't think so I
think if you looked up history you'll
find out that a lot of those books just
come from the school known as the Lyceum
and there were lots of students lots of
brains in there they develop things and
this whole body of knowledge is all
attributed to Aristotle in fact about a
few years about a little over 10 years
after Aristotle came to Athens he was
kicked out he had to run for his life
because Alexander had been murdered in
Persia and and Athenians rebelled
against against Macedonia and Macedonia
beat them and that was the end of what
we know today is the what is it the
classical Athens this is when Athens
finished its Classical period with the
death or the exile voluntary exile of
Aristotle anyways the deal here is that
by the way here's a little picture here
of what the Lyceum looks like today just
the foundations are left and this is
what an artist
thought you know it looked like in those
days
lots of people gathering and they would
talk about physics and politics and
religion who knows what tonight so it's
a gathering place a marketplace so to
speak you know people just went there to
suffice anyways what Aristotle did he
developed a language to try to figure
out causes and mechanisms in he wanted
to know why things happen and what
causes them to happen which is the right
notion for physics the mathematicians
today dismissed that as philosophy and
it's the other way around what they do
is philosophy mathematics all that stuff
if anything is part of a philosophy we
call religion it has nothing to do with
science science is about explaining and
that's what Aristotle tried to do in
order to do so he developed a certain
fishy physics right what he tried to do
is define some terms that he think he
thought he would need in order to make
his case and he defined words that I
personally don't have any use for in
physics in general I think has no use
for any of these terms these terms have
to do with geometry but not with physics
and geometry is no is not a French of
physics okay geometry is a bank branch
branch of mathematics and it should stay
there and none of those two belong to
science let alone the fizzy science in
science we explain physics we explain
causes and mechanisms which is what
Aristotle try to do mathematics and
geometry only described it doesn't
explain anything okay so that's the
problem with geometry and math why they
are not part of physic why they're not
the language of physics well they're not
even a part of science yeah yeah I hope
that's clear and you don't have to agree
you just have to defend your point okay
anyways these are the words that
Aristotle thought were important and the
ones he defined it you will see that
they are related to the point and the
line of geometry so you can get a good
guess that you could borrow a lot of
stuff if not from Aristotle at least
from the entire Lyceum the whole school
that you know Aristotle created and so
he defines things like together things
in one place apart things in different
places okay very very profound okay
contact touch okay extremities are
together then very simple straight
I think those are I've summarized these
because here it's a little more right
here we get to two difficult ones which
I outlined in green there because they
are a little tricky and in the first one
you should really leave the red part out
the part that's underlined in red
because without that sense it's it's
easier to read okay so if you say that
which a that which a changing thing
naturally reaches before it reaches that
to which it changes last okay it's
easier to read that way and may not make
any sense to you right now let me give
me a second I'll I'll illustrate it for
you second one in succession which is
somewhat different than between right
after the beginning in position or in
form and there is nothing of the same
kind as itself between it and that to
which it is in succession what does this
all mean I decided to illustrate it
because these are somewhat you know
tongue twisters see if I can give this
thing here so here's the my illustration
of this so that you can get it you know
so you don't have to break your brains
trying to figure out what you see you
have the top one is in succession the
bottom one is in between what Aristotle
is saying is if something moves with for
example uniform motion okay if they're
stuck together they're touching then you
have succession not really touchy but if
if there's no space between them then
it's which is essentially the definition
of touch right then they're in
succession otherwise if one moves and
the other one separates somehow within
our body then we have what he calls
between okay and you have to keep in
mind that Aristotle did not believe in
empty space he believed that as soon as
something moves something occupies its
space that's its place right so so it's
just that
the in-between is the object that
occupied the space that's what he's
saying and now if it's the same object
if both objects are moving
simultaneously then there is no in
between in between happens only when
there's a space that something else
fills in that's the notion he wants to
give to you okay and again I don't know
how important those are but they were
important for his definition here it is
again and what else does he say well he
says contiguous and continues contiguous
a thing that is in succession and
touches if he's got to talk about touch
he's no longer talking about concepts
see in the case of between and in
succession
he's using the he's emphasizing the
first one the word change in the second
one he's emphasizing what was the word
the position he's talking about position
okay so it's a little different than the
first three where he talks about a thing
being in a certain place or contact two
things touching each other
contiguous is the same notion here he's
using things okay not concepts he's not
saying that love is touching
intelligence he's saying that a thing
touches another thing a Rock touches a
tree okay that's what he's talking about
and he's getting obviously gonna talk
about points and lines that's where he's
headed with all this geometry again okay
and the important word is continues why
because he's gonna he's gonna make
several arguments one argument is the
argument of infinity that's what he's
going towards he's kind of head towards
this word infinity and that's a big
problem because infinity has to do as
he's gonna be using it with a number
line it's got to do with time it's got
to do with motion yeah incessant motion
which he calls infinite infinite motion
or infinity and and that's where we get
the words confused
and that's where he gets away from
geometry because what does all that have
to do with geometry okay
so you talk about location instead of
talking about point the dot okay
so when he needs to talk about touch he
uses the dot and when he needs to talk
about infinity and cetera he can't use
the dot unless you're talking about
counting dots in which he's talking the
case he's talking about numbers which
has nothing really to do with geometry
proper because proper because geometry
above all needs a shape it's your study
of shapes and sizes yeah anyways the
word continues things are called
continuous when the touching limits of
each become one and the same he's
talking about an object that is made of
a single piece as I I like to put it you
know in physical terms continuty is
impossible if these extremities are two
hey so essentially he's saying you know
talking about objects and you say it's
got to be made of a single piece in
order for it to meet the definition his
definition of continuity okay of
continues okay let's move on here see if
I can get this other one here and he
what is he referring to he's referring
to the line he's saying the line is made
of a single piece and it's interesting
how he puts that in this following
context listen to this one this is
important because suddenly he pulls a
rabbit out of the hat without you
knowing
he says if as some say point and unit
have an independent existence of their
own it is impossible for the two to be
identical four points can touch while
units can only be in succession okay so
in the case of unis he's saying once
right after another he's talking about
numbers in case of points thoughts right
he said they can touch because what
we're talking about physical objects
we're not talking about locations
touching each other we're talking about
dots talking touching each other let's
keep that in mind
moreover there can always be something
between points Oh what can be between
two points for all lines are
intermediate between points
what separates two points a line what is
a line distance he's talking about
distance he calls it a line he's using
geometric objects such as line to
separate two points okay what's he
talking about he's talking about
distance but he uses the line as a
pictorial representation of that
distance suddenly he introduces geometry
shapes with has no requirement there's
no necessity introduced a line in this
context okay and where is that is not
necessary that there should be should
possibly be anything between units what
is he talking about numbers for there
can be nothing between the numbers 1 & 2
so the numbers 1 & 2 are not separated
by distance or lines because the one
comes right after another okay whereas
between two dots right what do you call
them points between two dots if there is
a distance well that distance is a line
so you figure it out what does the line
mean in that concept if not distance he
is talking about distance anyways this
is this is the starting point okay and
from here you know oh here this is this
is where it leads these are I just want
to summarize this okay this is what
Aristotle was referring to he's using
point in line to talk about not geometry
he's talking about location distance
motion time numbers the number line
that's the context of where all this is
headed to and he's gonna be using that
in the next couple books that he writes
he wrote this book physics no composed
of eight books and this is in book five
by the time he gets the book aid well
you know he is developed this in a
geometric sensor or use it to your
metric argument so point and
in lieu to pictorially represent
location distance motion and time and
number really the number line that's
what he's talking about because he's
gonna talk about infinity okay
okay so that's uh that's the starting
point
and it's the starting point for mr.
Aquinas and the other day I talked about
you know what Aquinas was doing here
right he was saying he was talking about
angels and these are some of the
properties he assigns to angels they're
all together whether he asks these
questions he tries to answer these
questions whether the angels are
incorporeal whether they're composed of
matter and form whether they're infinite
numbers of them are great numbers of
them they different types right species
whether an angel has a location where
it's in a place or whether several
whether an angel can be at several
places that want to whether its many
angels can be at one place and whether
it passes through the intermediate space
does an angel go to from A to C and
passes through B or does it go directly
to C and whether the movement of an
angel is instantaneous and for some
strange reason you know the these are
the same questions that we have missed
the followers of mr. Bohr and he's one
of the founders one of the key founders
of quantum mechanics and all those
questions apply to particles as well and
you probably heard a lot of those
notions those questions as applied to
quantum mechanics or being address today
by quantum mechanics yeah
so this is again the starting point and
so here we have mr. Tom again and he
goes with that first question whether
neat Julie is altogether incorporeal
does is an angel made of substance is it
isn't made about something whatever you
know or is he I hate to say be I don't
put words in his mouth but what he's
saying is you know is an angel a concept
there isn't an object object that which
has shape
a concept is that which does it and so
if it's corporeal then it's an object
very simple and it's a black or white
and the question is is there anything in
between and so he says every body is
limited to here and now okay so you have
a temporal and a physical location yeah
that's for a body okay the perfection of
the universe requires the existence of
in court and incorporeal creature it
requires it sounds a lot like quantum
mechanics so far you know requires
incorporeal creatures of particles right
incorporeal substances ranked between
God and corporeal creatures between us
and God there's all these intermediate
Gray's Hades maybes the Angels compared
to God our material and corporeal not
however as if anything corporeal existed
in them and angels called an ever mobile
substance and not as as if he were
sometimes actually and sometimes
potentially as we are okay so you say
some of the Angels someone between God
and us we for us he is spiritual he is
insubstantial incorporeal for God he is
corporeal he is substantial he is made
out of something or matter God didn't
see him or seizes his body or whatever
so for God he's material but for us he
is spiritual you figure it out it's like
covering all the bases trying to get the
best of both worlds to be circumscribed
by local limits belongs to bodies only
okay so you can't be circumscribed to by
limits because then you become I guess
human you become a real material thing
and you don't want to really hold the
angel to that and an Angels above that
because is not God but he's between God
and humans right
okay so what does quantum mechanics say
to all this does it have a parallel and
I think it does and here you see some
there's are the people disciplines of
mr. Bohr and they have invented what is
known as the virtual particle what is a
virtual particle a transient quantum
acquaintance fluctuation that exhibits
some of the characteristics of an
ordinary particle while having is
existence limited by the uncertainty
principle which is down there below the
term is somewhat loose and vaguely
defined no kidding
may be self-serving li real particles
are better understood to be excitations
of the underlying quantum fields virtual
particles are also excitations of the
underlying fields but are temporary they
last only for a fleeting second or
microsecond the uncertainty principle
says that we cannot measure the position
of momentum a momentum of a particle
with absolute precision simultaneously
the more accurately we know one of these
values the less accurately we know the
other that's essentially the notion that
they have of the uncertainty principle
and because of this rock-solid principle
we invented virtual particles we allow
them to exist for whatever time they
want because you know uncertainty
principle allows for it and we haven't
stopped at the virtual particle we have
also invented the quasi or quasi
particle okay and the quasi particle
collective excitations emergent
phenomena that occur when a
microscopically complicated system such
as a solid behaves as if it contained
different weakly interacting particles
in free space okay so again all these
are ghosts and goblins that quantum
mechanics has resemble quite a bit the
angels that that
mr. Aquinas invented and so the question
is what is a quasi particle is it an
angel just like Aquinas said or is it a
field that's vibrating is it a bunch of
numbers that are vibrating is it a
particle like that red dot in the center
or is it a leprechaun I mean what is a
quasi particle what are we talking about
it's like these people have invented all
these notions just to get around the
explanations we cannot understand with
these notions as these people developed
we cannot understand their explanation
we cannot figure what their physical
interpretation is if they're going to
use quasi particles and they're going to
use virtual particles because what are
they saying they're saying well the
particle just pops in from the void
whenever it wants to whenever we're
trying to do something suddenly another
particle pops in we don't see it we
can't measure we infer that it's there
because something happens so the
particle came in and then went back out
sounds a lot like an angel I mean the
angel move my curtain I'm sure that okay
I'm sure that the angel moved my curtain
did you take a picture of him did you
grab him did you talk to him no he went
back and turned into space again so he
came he moved the curtain and just went
out and so I have to say well that was
done by well it wasn't done by a what is
a virtual particle I had to be done by
an angel right or maybe I should just
shut the window
anyways quantum mechanics this is what
they have in mind the mechanics they say
look we have this you know sheet the
space-time sheet and it's got its
vibrating it's all this vibration that
forms the background the the vacuum
that's in the background yeah this is
the vacuum energy and from this vacuum
energy what we have is suddenly you know
a virtual particle pops out of there and
it goes something like this see you have
the vibration of the waves
suddenly two particles appear particle
and antiparticle of course right and you
have opposite polarities and so they
come together and they collapse into
nothing they go back to being a wave or
part of that vibration in the background
and from that same vibration comes in a
pair of particles that turn you know
into real particles that do something in
the real world for a fleeting second and
then go back to becoming part of space
or vacuum or whatever they call it
and here's another addition of that you
have a little wave it turns into a
particle and back to a wave and back and
forth and these things pop in from from
the void and that's why these people
cannot give you a classical or rational
as I call it a rational answer to any
physical interpretation well what they
what they say is look particles appear
from the void and it's all that
fluctuation that's going on in the
vacuum that's happening okay and that's
the reason that we cannot explain it in
rational tone in terms that you would
understand the math doesn't lie it's
there and the experiments prove it but
we cannot explain it to you except with
these virtual particles that's home how
you know pop in and go out and you know
it's all these waves that turn into
particle momentarily and then go back to
being waves or field or energy or
whatever nonsense word that has been
invented I think the best word is angel
II I think you know I think they're just
trying to steal the Nobel Prize away
from mr. Aquinas I mean he deserves a
Nobel Prize because he said it first and
he said it with angels these people say
well what are we gonna do now well let's
call it particle and we get rid of
Aquinas completely he doesn't you know
get his no but we do it you know all we
did is just what give it new names is
that it because it's still an Angels got
the same powers and magical properties
that attributes you know that the
ancients had anyways so what is this
vacuum you know you you wonder because
you're saying hold it the vacuum is
Eirene I thought the vacuum was nothing
what is back to you and so you go up
there and you look it up and this is
what mr. Bohr and his discipline believe
the vacuum is this is the definition you
get today this out of Wikipedia but I
guess it's the same everywhere it
doesn't matter vacuum is space okay keep
that word in mind space thank you miss
space devoid of matter okay so we have
space that has matter if we take all the
matter out we get what is called vacuum
okay got it I think I think I got it
okay an approximation to such a vacuum
is a region with a gaseous pressure much
less than atmospheric pressure that's an
approximation to vacuum saying that one
that has very little matter well that's
all a wrong definition that's just an
approximation the real definition is
that first one you know it's devoid of
matter that's vacuum okay let's keep
that in mind
physicists often discuss ideal test
results that would occur in a perfect
vacuum which they sometimes simply call
vacuum or free space
okay keep those terms in mind if you can
vacuum free space that's the same thing
as perfect vacuum
no matter whatsoever and use the term
partial vacuum to refer to an actual
imperfect vacuum as one might have any
laboratory or in space okay yeah I work
with us so you pump out lots of matter
and you don't have a perfect vacuum and
they call that an imperfect vacuum or
space because what is space space is
that which still has matter vacuum is
total absence of matter okay in
Engineering and Applied Physics on the
other hand vacuum refers to any space in
which the pressure is considerably lower
than atmospheric pressure in other words
we have a little confusion because
according to this engineers and flight
physicists they say there's no such
thing as vacuum we need us something a
little more practical more pragmatic and
so our so called vacuum is really not
total vac
that vacuum is really full of particles
which means that vacuum is the same
thing in that space there means that
space has particles in it okay that's
what space is according to these
definitions space some particles at
least vacuum total absence of particles
why don't they just call it space now
they call it vacuum and confuse you
completely because they said well our
vacuum is different than their vacuum
their vacuum is a free vacuum a total
vacuum a perfect vacuum and our vacuum
has some particles in it because we
cannot cheat total vacuum so we call it
a ricardo vacuum to confuse everybody
okay so we have a vacuum that is not a
vacuum we have a vacuum that is space
space has particles vacuum doesn't but
their vacuum has particles in it it just
has less particles than atmospheric
pressure that's the notion okay so what
is a space thing I mean I want to know
what space is now because that's the
keyword they use in this definition so
here we have this word space space is
the boundless three-dimensional extent
what's an extent extent of what and what
do you mean space is 3-dimensional are
you saying it's like a cube it's like a
ball is like a pyramid I mean what do
you mean three dimension space I thought
was nothing which is what the first
definition says space the void of matter
it gives you a vacuum so vacuum plus
matter equal space and now suddenly this
space turns into a physical container of
sorts it's three dimensional okay in
which objects and events have relative
position and direction I don't know how
an object can have you know if space is
an object itself how can you say that
objects occupy spaces spaces an object
again are we talking about a container
is that what spaces and so he continues
that or the definition continues
physical space is physical space I mean
space made out of something physical
it's often conceived in three linear
dimensions although modern physicists
usually consider it with
to be part of the boundless
four-dimensional continuum known as
space-time not the words they use extent
continuum you know I don't know what an
extent this I never was able to draw one
or a nursing an illustration of a
continuum yeah what are these words yeah
they're they use these fancy words and
we don't know what they're talking about
spaces and extent spaces of continuum
that says the concept of space so I
thought it was an object but now it
turns out that space is a concept it is
considered to be of fundamental
importance to an understanding of the
physical universe thank God you know and
glad that it's a part of the foundations
of physics right however disagreement
continues between philosophers
philosophers over whether it is itself
an entity a relationship between
entities or part of a conceptual network
ok now how's that for for a perfect
definition a unambiguous definition okay
I guess you can take that to the bank
right okay but we continue turns out
there is another like a little corollary
to in here we continue with that
definition and so what are they saying
they saying that space is one of the few
fundamental quantities in physics
meaning that it cannot be defined by
other quantities because nothing more
fundamental is known at the present okay
what they're saying is they don't know
what space is made out oh yeah okay on
the other hand it can be related to
other fundamental quantities quantities
what we are they saying that space is a
quantity what are we talking about it's
an extent it's a what was a manifold or
whatever they said continuum and the
quantities
it's a quantity so now I have no idea
what a space is what are they mean by
space that's similar to other
fundamental quantities okay like time
and mass space can be explored by a
measurement and experiment so you need
to measure something to figure out what
spaces I thought you just need a good
definition to know what space is and how
are you going to prove the existence of
space through an experiment
what experiment you gonna run the space
what do you had to take it to the lab
and do I don't know
chocolate juggle the the particles of
space I don't know whether what
experiment can you do in space I don't
know what you can do okay
today are three dimensional space big
object I hope you see it someday it's a
three dimensional something out there
called space today
is viewed as embedded in a
four-dimensional space-time they put it
outside your reach the idea behind
space-time is that time is hyperbolic
orthogonal to each of the three spatial
dimensions my god so so we have the
space-time that includes space which is
three dimensional with some kind of
container they can't draw it but they
say contains everything you figure it
out okay so that's the story so far
let's move on here
good old Tom goes to the second question
second issue and get it up here okay and
it's a weather an angel is composed of
matter and form what is an angel made
out what is a particle made out of hey I
mean so far the particle seems quite
weird because comes out of space
whenever it wants to goes back into
space we don't know what space is
they call it vacuums vacuum has
different definitions and they never
define the vacuum they just say it's
space without particles that's what
vacuum is whatever that is you know says
matter is not divisible into parts
except as regarded under the quality and
quantity and without quantity substance
is indivisible Hey so essentially
they're saying you can divide objects
therefore it would follow that the
matter of spiritual things is talking
about angels right is subject to
quantity which cannot be okay so saying
that you know in an angel you you cannot
subdivide you cannot cut in half because
what because you may be cutting a
concept you know
love in half that's more or less the
notion that he's putting out here
therefore it is impossible that
corporeal and spiritual things should
have the same matter so we're not made
as the same matter as angels okay and I
guess we're not made in the same manner
as quantum particles because you know we
seem to have different properties and
the quantum particles particles can be
at two places at once the particles that
comprise me you know they can be a new
place that one thought I can't be at two
places at once and that's kind of weird
because these particles can and I can't
and they make me they are made of them
okay okay so he said essentially what I
say objects you can divide concepts you
can't
that's essentially what Aquinas is
saying so yeah we have an angel okay and
the question is whether you can divide
that angel okay and let's see if we can
do that because see you have a shape on
the earth there you can see something
there there's a contrast the Angels the
white stuff in the center over there
okay
and what happens if we try to cut that
in half here it is what cut it in half I
guess I was able to cut the angel in
half I mean give me any object I should
be able to mentally cut it in half slice
it down the middle okay I think I can do
that with any object in the universe
even with a picture of an object right
and of course if the angel is
representative of good something that's
nice
yeah you can't chop good in half okay
what are you chopping because Pete is a
concept I mean can you chop chop love in
half can you chop intelligence in half
you know it doesn't make no sense and
this goes back to Aristotle who said you
know again the definitions of continuous
versus the definition of contiguous and
you know they apply to objects you can't
apply see if they have
you can't extrapolate that property to
concepts you can't say love touched
intelligence you can't say that it's
other than poetically but you can't say
that in physics it's science and so you
know again you have to decide with that
the angel is that little flapping thing
that's got wings
you know flying out here I can see that
thing it's got shape I can mentally cut
it in half but if the angel is just a
pictorial represent that representation
of good well I can't chop good in half
and that's more or less what the problem
war has you know here we have here's the
field so we're gonna chop it in half
how's that yeah we chop the field in
half does that make sense can you chop a
concept such as a field what is a field
well they say that a point or a particle
is a vibrating field it's an excited
field that's what that's what a particle
is and so why shouldn't I be able to
chop it in half if it's just a particle
of course if it's a concept that is
vibrating out there for example here
let's see if I can see put this up here
here's the half a field of vibrating
numbers you have a field and a half a
field how's that I mean if if a field is
just a bunch of vibrating numbers which
is what how it's defined just a bunch of
numbers coming out of and becoming
weaker farther and farther away from an
object then yes you can't chop that in
half
you can't chop values in half physically
you can chop them mathematically but not
physically that's the point yeah so
we've got a problem with these notions
of going back and forth between objects
and concepts and that's that's
essentially the problem that we have
with quantum mechanics and the guy who
came up with all that stuff is obviously
mr. Aquinas already he had developed
those notions almost a thousand years
anyways here we have the math
point getting back to geometry we have
the dot and yeah I can pet the dot in
half I'll have half a dot but if the dot
represents location if that's just a
pictorial representation of location I
don't think I can chop a location in
half I mean what meaning does that have
to have I mean a diamond top
two-dimensional so it's now
two-dimensional / - can I chop a an
ordered pair you know have an X in wine
does it make sense to say well I'm gonna
chop it in half you know how many steps
to the treasure chest well it's 10 on
the x-axis 20 on the y-axis so I chop it
in half I leave 10 over here and then 20
over there does that make any sense
chopping a concept such as an ordered
pair which represents or which the dot
represents does that make sense
chop it in half and that's what these
people are doing essentially I mean when
they go back and forth between math and
physics between geometry and physics
they bring in the dot when they need to
explain something pictorially for you to
see with your own eyes and then they go
back to the concept and they jump back
and forth and people don't realize that
that's what's happening and that's why a
lot of people don't understand a lot of
this stuff because they say yeah I
understand squad yeah I sympathize with
you okay okay where do we stop well we
don't stop we have here mr. Aquinas he
goes a step further and he says he goes
again the next day and whether an angel
is composed of matter in form he says it
is further impossible for an
intellectual substance that have any
kind of matter angelic substances are
above our intellect and hence our
intellect cannot attain to comprehend
them to comprehend them you cannot
understand this what they're doing is or
what he's doing is placing God beyond
your reach or angels in this case he's
putting none beyond your reach he's
saying that you cannot even in
imagine this thing so don't even try
other people say you know one of the
answers I got once is that if I could
tell you what God is that God would be
so great that's a good answer that's the
type of answer you'll get you'll never
know what God is you won't know what an
angel is because you know they doesn't
put his finger on he just says look it's
beyond your reach you won't understand
it so don't even try okay so uh you know
a lot of atheists say will prove the
endure existence then if you can't even
make sense of what you're saying okay if
you don't know what you're talking about
but see it doesn't get relegated to
religion only here we have mr. Leonardo
second he's a Stanford professor of
mathematical physics which we know as
mathematics and this is what he says as
well I mean what did a good ol mr.
Aquinas say just now he says you know
I'm gonna put that beyond your reach so
you can't even question you cannot put
me against the ropes and pummel me
because I'm just gonna put it beyond
your minds reach so what are the quantum
mechanics do how do they explain stuff
well here you have it he says more or
less the same thing says you and I
evolved in the world of three dimensions
we can't visualize more dimensions I can
visualize three dimensions in my head
but I use X Y & Z to describe them
mathematically note that he uses the
word describe now I go to four
dimensions or five dimensions I can't
visualize them anymore I can't say now
close your eyes and view in your head
five dimensions because I can't do it
either so we're stuck needing
mathematics because evolution didn't
equip us to be able to visualize quantum
mechanics it didn't equip us to
visualize eleven dimensional space times
evolution did this to us okay any
difference between mr. Aquinas and what
we find in quantum mechanics I don't
think so I think they're pretty much the
same I don't think the mathematicians of
the Roaring Twenties who develop quantum
mechanics you know invented anything new
all these
notions existed with 900 years ago 800
years ago they've been around for a
quite a while and a quite I wasn't the
first one there were other like both
years I talked about the other day that
already had come up with a lot of these
notions they try to make sense of the
invisible world around them and they
introduced angels they had no other way
of relating to some of the miracles that
they saw happening around them they said
what is light what is fire what is the
air you know they could see all this
stuff and they said Oh in many cases not
always but they said angel and then they
had to say well how does it how does the
wind go from here to there let's go
through another mediate space what's the
angel you know go through from your
there yeah they would explain it in
terms of angel spirits
magical stuff from heaven etc what is
different from quantum mechanics today I
mean they're doing the same thing
they're saying oh virtual particle oh
that's a quasi particle oh that's a
tachyon it comes from the future what is
it is is this science is this physics or
is this more angelic stuff and that's
for you to decide anyways I'm gonna
continue with some of the questions that
mr. Aquinas addressed okay and I just
want you to know that tomorrow one going
under the knife okay I'm gonna have an
operation some of you are aware I'm in
what was it September October I was in
the hospital for three weeks I had a
bacterial infection my left leg and
during the course of that convalescence
I the doctors discovered that I've got a
bad thing so they're gonna operate my
vein they're gonna take it out or
they're gonna kill it inside delay and
yeah it's not a delicate operation like
brain surgery or art surgery but you
know whenever you're knocked out you
know you may not come back so it's
always there is some some risks on
danger always when you're totally
unnecessary
and so I'm gonna be in there tomorrow
and we'll see if I come out of it
hopefully I do and I'll be back here on
Sunday so if you don't see me on Sunday
you know what happened I never made it
hopefully I do and I'll see you on
Sunday we'll see you that bye bye